so let's play some fill in the bright
blank Chris
aside from new personnel in Houston we
talked about the changes on offense the
biggest change that the Texans offense
need right now is what well you know
variety is the word that comes in my
mind and in two different you know areas
here variety in some of the schematic
aplace that the offense runs with the
Houston Texans you know they can be a
little basic and stale at times if I was
going to sit here and be honest and
compare it to the other really creative
offenses in football but the big thing
is we're variety comes into play is
something you hit on already Mike I mean
the shot I mean
deshaun Watson to DeAndre Hopkins
Deshawn Watson's and DeAndre Hopkins
deshaun Watson to DeAndre Hopkins that's
the only thing that's been going on in
Houston the last three or four years I
mean last year it's more than double
output double the output of anybody on
the roster as far as receptions the
years before that
it's triple and quadruple the you know
as far as the gap between his receptions
and second and third on the team in
receptions he just was always going to
him so you know I think the fact that
they got you know Brandon stills and
Kyle full or will fuller who's been
heard a lot of he could stay healthy
he's a game changers we know but then to
have cooks with him and Randall Cobb I
do think it's gonna make this offense a
little different this year and that you
won't be able to hone in on one guy and
you're gonna go okay all these guys are
viable options they are good route
runners and it might make the offense
harder to defend as a whole might not
take off right away but at the end of
the season that might be better than
just Watson to Hopkins here's what the
offense needs in my opinion and this is
the direct influence of working with you
for the last three years one of the
things I've learned from having having
the benefit of your insight and
knowledge on how offenses work they need
plays that happen quickly that are
designed to work right off the bat you
go you get the ball and you throw it you
get a guy with no completions yeah easy
completions that the Sean Payton plays
where and we have some Sean Payton plays
coming up later in the
program where it makes the quarterback
look good the job is easy it's designed
so that from the get-go your guys going
to be open because what do we see with
deshaun Watson all the time he's holding
on to the ball he's running around every
play is like it's the last play of the
Super Bowl in a dragging something
happened and the longer that he's doing
that the greater the chance he's gonna
get hit the more times he gets hit the
greater the chance he's gonna get hurt
they need to figure out how to move the
ball without deshaun Watson having a
hold on to the ball for eight seconds
Chris I'm with you Mike I'm with you
it's one of the things that scares me
they put a lot on his plate on a you
know play-by-play weekly basis that way
and you're right he still has a you know
last play of the game type mentality
where it's never over I would that mean
that's what I was talking about with the
variety of schemes a little bit is you
know they need to find some of those
no-brainer easy completions for deshaun
Watson you know whether those are you
know quick screen passes like we've seen
you know Brady throw to Julian Edelman
you know Julian Edelman with blockers in
front of them or those quick throws that
we see Rodgers make the Davante Adams
and they got a bunch of blockers in
front of them yeah those are big for a
quarterback you know they take them they
give you a player to off mentally to
where you can just come to the line you
don't have to worry about oh what am I
seeing the defense the right way do I
have to get the right check you know
nobody's perfect you're gonna mess up at
some point even paint Manning and Brady
mess up every now and then so to have
plays like that are one physically good
for the quarterback and to mentally good
for the quarterback and the offense in
general so I'm with you there buddy that
was a good one I think it also it also
affects the defense in a negative way
you get them on their heels they get
that what the hell is going on out here
attitude and and I think it becomes
easier to impose your will on them where
where the plays aren't designed from the
get-go to to lead to an easy completion
and an easy first down yes I think
that's that's that's the big thing you
know and especially you know the big
thing is with some of those plays you're
talking about - you can vary up the snap
count right you know some of those slam
dunk easy completions you don't need to
go up there and diagnose so you can just
get up there and you know set hut or
blue go and just go which also will give
you a schematic advantage on the defense
who's sitting there way
for a snap count now they're going
minute they gonna snap it quick is gonna
be a dummy snap count it's gonna be a
you know on two what are they getting so
they that'll add to having them on their
heels and not knowing what to expect and
that's what the great offenses do they
keep you off balance that way make you
defend the whole field as we've talked
about a whole lot and certainly a great
offensive coordinator can find a lot of
easy ways to give us quarterback some
cheap completions every game yeah next
thing you know you get guys jumping
offside because you don't know when the
hell the snap counts gonna be and you
pick up right cheap yards here they're a
couple of times during the course of the
game cumulatively that can make a huge
difference all right Jay Gruden is the
new offensive coordinator of the
Jacksonville Jaguars they are giving
gardner minshew every opportunity to
show that he's the guy compared to his
rookie year you would expect gardner
Manchus 2020 to be what chris you know
I'm gonna say better I don't know what
other way to say say this year but
either way you know again it was a great
start with how he started his rookie
here twenty one touchdown six
interceptions makes plays when you know
things aren't there I guess what I want
to say is I think they'll play through
Gardner 2020 will be an offense that's
run through Gardner Minshew more then
maybe last year where they managed him
and ran the ball and hey he's a rookie
let's not put too much on his plate I
think they know the DNA of this guy what
he's capable of handling Jay Gruden's
got great people skills it's a really
good offense it's gonna really fit the
skillset of Gardner Minshew and I think
they'll empower him this year that'll be
the big thing he's gonna have more
control at the line of scrimmage they're
gonna trust him with more variety of
plays to when the offensive side of the
ball to where yeah he was a rookie and
they probably reined it in a little bit
to not overwhelm overwhelm him and make
him feel comfortable you know there's
there's an attitude though there's an
edge that comes from talking to people
with the Jaguars I had Dave Caldwell on
the PF TM podcast a few weeks back he's
the Jaguars general manager the guy who
who found Gardner Minshew in the sixth
round out of Washington State in 2019 he
would make the argument that Minshew had
a better rookie season in Kyler's Murray
what
I'm not ready to sign on for that yeah
and and Dave Caldwell crossed the
boundary into what is a findable offense
in these parts by invoking quarterback
wins as a statistic for a quarterback
even the factor
he's a factor in making the guys around
him play better it's not a quarterback
stat to say you've got a better win-loss
record because there's so much else
including the quality of your defense
most important part of that but but
minshew was good last year you know we
have I think we have this vague
perception of Minshew because he got
thrust into the fray out of the blue we
didn't know who the hell the guy was
right when it comes week one nick foles
breaks a collarbone
he plays pretty well but then he
essentially got benched later in the
year for Falls I mean they could have
kept foals on the sidelines if min she
was playing really well they would have
he got to a point where he plateaued and
maybe regressed a little bit and they
yanked him out and then they put him
back in but there's that that that kind
of that that that black mark on his
resume from last year where are they
ambivalent about him do they really
believe in him and I think they do now
but I think that you know he didn't have
that wire-to-wire great year that makes
us say like we do with Tyler Murray oh
he's definitely the guy no III think
that's it and you know you you know you
could sit here and go oh yeah he had a
better year than Kyle Emery no he did
not
I'm sorry is as good as it was for
Gardner Minshew you're right he hit a
really rough patch in the middle of the
year and hey this will be the big point
when Kyle Emery cept on the field from
the Arizona Cardinals they were like hey
there buddy you're we're gonna throw the
ball a lot we're gonna put you in the
shotgun it's all about you you've got to
carry the team you've got to make it
happen
Gardner Minshew got Leonard fournette
who was one of the top rushers in
football they played a different style
to where it wasn't on him on a
play-by-play basis to carry the team the
franchise was thrown on the back of Kyle
Emery from the get-go and he didn't
blink and nobody else did so that's the
difference between the year of Gardner
Minshew and Kyle Emery you know yeah
there was a little bit more of managing
of situations with Gardner Minshew to
your point into what you're saying there
and speaking of Kyler murray and the
arizona cardinals running back Kenyan
Drake says his ceiling is as high as he
will take it what is this ceiling for
the Cardinals Chris the ceiling is
lank well I'm gonna say wildcard
wildcard round like somewhere you know
as a six or seven seed to me that's the
ceiling I don't look at them and go oh
they're gonna win the NFC West this year
I don't think they're there yet they're
trending upwards I'm excited about them
but I think ultimately that's how I look
at the ceiling is a you know low seeded
playoff appearance for the Cardinals
this year how do you feel about that
Mike
well I remember there's a seventh seed
now in the NFC and we've already talked
about the possibility that all four
teams from the NFC West could make it to
the postseason now because you've got
three wild cards not two and there's no
limitation on the number that comes from
any one division and the NFC West
clearly the best division in the
conference if not the best division in
all of football you know last Friday
big cat and I answered a question from a
viewer about teams that could go worse
to first and we both kind of pegged the
Cardinals as a possibility not a strong
possibility but one that wouldn't shock
us they were fourth place last year in
that division
you know you get enough enough for that
that beating up on each other within the
division and the curve right Seahawks in
Seattle and they gave the 49ers a hard
time twice you win a couple of those
games this year instead of lose them and
maybe try to mix to win the division
Chris it's not quite against it's
nothing winning the NFC West ooh wow
that's that's strong yeah I don't think
I would go that far but they've improved
their defense and I expect calimary with
DeAndre Hopkins and company for that
offense to be a lot more explosive this
year especially what we saw with the
emergence of Kenya and Drake at the end
of last season and all that too so yeah
I don't think they can win the NFC West
do I think they can be a really big pain
in the butt for everybody and be
competitive in the playoff conversation
I absolutely do
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports